I had a weird conversation last week
that I want to share with you that has
to do with generational wealth and right
now we're taking a deep dive in
generational wealth you know the Medici
family the Rothschild The Rockefellers
the Vanderbilt we have hundreds of pages
on generational wealth that is going to
lead to a webinar here so but stay tuned
I want to share two stories with you one
is what happened with the conversation
that I had that's a weird conversation
the other one is a story that's going to
inspire and get you thinking and if you
get value out of this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
so let me get right into it so Aaron
McKee is a basketball player NBA former
basketball player that's a coach now who
played for guy named John Chaney
legendary coach from Temple and John
Chaney told him something once this
video has been going viral it's an
unbelievable message here's how it goes
he says John Chaney says it to him John
Cheney says my grandfather walked 10
miles every day my father walked five
miles every day to school he says I
drive and escalate my son drives a
Mercedes most likely my grandson will
drive a Ferrari however my
great-grandson will be walking again
so grandfather 10 miles father five
miles himself escalates son Mercedes
grandson Ferrari great grandson will be
walking again why is that
so the person that walked 10 miles
worked so hard for their son to only
walk five miles and then they work so
hard so John Chaney can go get an
Escalade and he works so hard so his son
can have a Mercedes and he works also
his grandson can't have a Ferrari and
then great grandson loses everything
again why is it that so many
billionaires their generational wealth
doesn't make you to third generation do
you know the Vanderbilts were the
richest people in the world and there's
not a single Vanderbilt you know today
and when Anderson Cooper when his mother
was talking to me says mom how much
money should I be expecting since we're
a sixth generation Vanderbilt mom says
son you don't have a trust fund coming
your way because someone screwed it up
by the second generation buying 165 000
square foot vacation homes is what they
were doing anyways what's my point
here's my point
I'm having a conversation this last week
with one of our uh one somebody that I'm
mentoring and I'm helping them out with
their business plan
and the conversation goes and we're
talking talking all of a sudden they say
well look you know you've now made a lot
of money and you know so it's you have a
lot of money now and investments in bank
and all this other stuff and I noticed
they've gotten extremely casual and soft
in the way they do business their
standards used to be very high but now
it's all casual and I'm like
on a flight back I'm thinking about
these guys thinking why have these
people all of a sudden got so casual
so I call back I said I got to talk to
these guys so I get on the phone I call
them and I say hey
the other day when we were talking you
made a couple different comments
and I noticed those comments you made
your standards have dropped since June
27th why is that
silence
I'm actually curious I want to know
because June 27 is the day where the
event took place when we sold one of our
insurance companies
and I said do you think
that just because I all of a sudden got
access to a ton of capital
that I'm all of a sudden going to slow
down and kick back and relax the next
day
so did you think I was going to treat a
massive Moment Like This financially the
way you would have maybe treated it
because to you this would have been such
a Monumental moment
don't assume I'm slowing down just
because I had a big exit
or all this Capital came my way
I said let me explain some to you what
my biggest concern is what's that
so for me I have four kids I have my 10
year old my nine-year-old my
six-year-old and my 15 month old named
Brooklyn
my 10 year old see me work my
nine-year-old see me work my
six-year-old see me work can you imagine
if let's just say by the six-year-old
you know we have all this money now or
my youngest daughter never knows about
how hard dad works he only she only
knows how hard that used to work where
it's kind of like yeah I mean everybody
tells me how our dad used to work I've
never seen her work hard because when I
was born that was always home it was
golfing it was kicking back I never saw
him work he was just chilling put on
weight gained a lot of weight he was
just relaxing having a drink every day
and I don't think I've ever seen my
daddy work that hard just told everybody
what to do and stayed home all day
that's unfair to her well the reason why
generational wealth doesn't get passed
down is because generational habits
don't get passed down like John Chaney
told the story to Aaron McKee about 10
miles five miles Cadillac Escalade
Mercedes Ferrari back to walking again
because you've heard this phrase before
it's not me telling you this first
you've heard this many many times before
tough times create strong leaders strong
leaders create good times good times
create weak leaders weak leaders create
what tough times and this cycle keeps
going so you
as a leader watching this you have a
family you got to sit there and say what
do I want to do my family
is it just hey I made the money so my
kids don't have to work that hard
[ __ ]
absolutely not it's not how this thing
works no way
I created wealth let's just say you do
or you have an incredible life right now
by creating wealth or an Incredible life
you've picked up a lot of great habits
what is more important to pass down to
them isn't the money
it's the habits so if you're watching
this right now yourself saying man this
kind of stings a little bit I fully
understand
I have kids I have a family and I've
done okay for myself and I would like
some of the habits that I picked up
throughout this journey to be passed
down to the people I work with most
importantly to be passed down to the
kids that I'm raising because if I don't
I'm just going to be raising four
spoiled kids that think it's okay to go
through whatever they're doing because
their daddy or their family has money
and I don't like kids like that I never
did in high school so I'm not going to
raise kids like that and you got to be
thinking about it for yourself as well
fastest way to judge somebody if they
have a big vision and if they think if
they think big is to see what they do
when they get nice money coming their
way it doesn't matter whether it's first
time I got ten thousand dollars that was
a lot of money to me first time I got
fifty thousand dollars it was a lot of
money to me I'd never made a hundred
thousand dollars before first time I
made a hundred thousand dollars oh my
God I'm a billionaire right matter of
fact it felt very different than the
last one but it doesn't matter you're
gonna have moments in your life and
every time you level up
um
and you start experiencing things value
more the habits and the character you're
developing more than the money that
that's coming your way because the
habits and character gets stronger more
money and success is going to come your
way having said that I did a video about
parenting how to raise successful
children if you've never seen this click
here to watch it